Although conditional entropy can tell us when two variables
are completely independent, it is not an adequate measure of
dependence. Now consider the conditional entropy of y given the
variable x. This conditional entropy may be small if x
tells us a great deal about y or that x of y is very small to begin with. So we
need another measure of dependence to measure the relationship between
x and y and we call that as mutual information.
It is denoted by the symbol I. And it is given as, the entropy of y, subtracted
by the entropy of x given y. So
mutual information is a measure of the reduction of
randomness of a variable given knowledge of some
other variable. If you like to understand the derivations
for these particular identities, I'll refer you to Charles's
notes on, on this topic. But we'll jump directly
into an example and try to calculate these
values and understand what it means to have a
high value of mutual information or low value of
mutual information. So let's do that as a quiz.